your father do so I was looking at this
video today of this dude
jumping this cliff in his bike like
Jamie was showing this one guy who does
this on buildings he does it like he he
rides his bike on like the ledges of
buildings and [ __ ] and jumps from
building to building and I was watching
this other guy jump this cliff with his
bike like literally jumps over one side
of the cliff and lands on to the other
it's [ __ ] like you're watching the
whole thing you know Jesus Christ if he
falls these dad he's [ __ ] dead that's
it's totally legal right like we were
talking about people think of an MMA is
barbaric that it should be illegal like
where should be you'd be allowed to take
your risks look at this [ __ ] guy this
guy's crazy dude look at this [ __ ]
hopping from building to building and
he's riding a bike on the edges of these
buildings this is [ __ ] insane
this guy's got just ridiculous control
of this bicycle I mean should this be
legal I don't know seems like he's doing
okay he was fine but if he [ __ ] up like
you know about that Chinese dude that
just died no he was one of those YouTube
guys that would take videos of him I
heard about the skyscrapers and [ __ ] and
he fell he fell to his death
damn yeah dude it looks ugly to look
scary like he was trying to claw himself
up and he couldn't then you see his hand
slip and you realized that's a wrap son
oh 600 feet I had a friend who was
training to be a BASE jumper and there's
things you got to do you know so many
regular skydiving jumps you got it you
got a master skydiving and just that
before you get into and then there's
things you have to do there's I could
listen
halfway through too many people died in
the scene or this person just stepped
back and said you know what maybe yeah
because it's not that uncommon were
these crazy base jumpers died or almost
died right yeah there's a lot of videos
there's one I saw that was awful this
Russian guy jumps off the top of this
building his parachute doesn't open up
in time and he bounces off the ground
and you hear him screaming OH
how about that one guys what do they
call that they'll call it BASE jumping
but they're like flying squirrels yes
that my friend Andy is the world record
holder and he stops the world record
holder
he flew what was it 18 miles I think he
covered eight wins that calls is it's a
flying wing suit yeah yeah but there's
one guy that's super famous for doing it
too and he's supposed to go through you
know they go down can we and he went
between two rocks and like his leg yeah
and then like [ __ ] he didn't die though
which is crazy well you know the one guy
that did died on the Golden Gate Bridge
you ever see that one he slammed right
into the bridge while people were
watching him he was supposed to go
between the wires Oh hit the bridge she
jumped off a plane crazier like he hit
it like like a bullet nobody jumped off
a plane and then went flying down and
tried to go through that I don't know
where he jumped off of I don't know if
he jumped off of a plane or he jumped
off of another bridge I don't know what
he did but when he was trying to do it
he literally slammed right into the
bridge and it sounds like a crazy car
accident like bang how long ago was that
know few years back this is all [ __ ]
give us some volume Jamie it wasn't
Golden Gate but San Francisco which
bridge was it it's horrible dude
Oh who's that in their parachute that's
another guy he was he was flying with
another guy oh my god dude
[ __ ] it sounded like there was a bunch
of people there watching - or - well
this is that should you'll be allowed to
do that I don't think you should be able
to tell someone they can't do something
right and why should you be able to why
what if what if they just start
influencing so many young kids to do it
and there's all these kids dying all
over the place then do you make it
illegal man that's a good question
well then do you make war illegal you
can't do that right how are we supposed
to eat like what's born when does it
become too dangerous like a what like
soccer people apparently some of them
get brain damage from heading the ball
apparently you're not supposed to head
things like that and they do it all the
time to practice they start developing
traumatic brain injuries they get CTE
from head-butting a ball so we you know
so that may be more dangerous than
wrestling yep you know